This episode is brought to you by curiosity stream,
the subscription streaming service that offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including exclusive originals,
unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month and 30 days for free.
If you sign up through the link below and use the code,
biographics more about them in a bit.
This is the nightmare I live with.
This is how today's protagonist describes the haunting memories of his
experience at the Auschwitz Birkenau extermination camp,
50 years after the events of world war two. But this man was a doctor,
not a Gordon's prisoner or heroin survivor. He was in fact,
an SS medical officer,
one of the many Nazi doctors who worked within the industry of death,
that the concentration camps served as the backbone of,
but unlike many of his more infamous peers,
this man went down in history as a good doctor,
a good man who did his best to save human lives or at minimum to
preserve a sliver of dignity for the camps prisoners,
his name was Hansville how much also known as the good man of Auschwitz.
She was born on may the 14th,
1911 in Freiburg in Bryce gal Barden,
then Barnes of the second German Reich.
His parents were Ernst and Matilda Nissan. Hung's inherited from Ernst,
an interest in science. And after graduating from high school,
he took up medicine, studying universities of Munich and tubing.
Again in 1933,
Hitler and the Nazi party were empowered and to gradually exerting influence
over every aspect of life. As the hands progressed in his medical studies,
he considered gaining formal party membership as a prerequisite to have,
and to keep any future job in later interviews,
Huntsman stated that he tolerated Nazi ideology,
but never actively supported it.
He was somewhat enthused by the patriotic rhetoric and he recognized that the
German economy as well for of the middle class had improved since the Nazis took
power. His family was even less enthusiastic about national socialism.
His father Ernst was completely indifferent while mum Matilda was strongly
opposed as per the antisemitic stance of the party. Well,
the entire family detested it wholeheartedly, but to Hans his own admission,
they never took it seriously. So the future Dr. Munch,
the antisemitic propaganda was this a more than empty words and bombast.
He could never believe that the Nazis would actually take violent systematic
actions against German Jews.
But these reasons in 1934 horns joins without much conviction to Nazi youth
organizations,
the national socialists mechanized core and the national socialist union of
students. It wasn't until may of 1937,
that Hans became a card carrying member of the Nazi party.
And even then it's happened almost by chance. As Hans completed his studies,
he entered a scientific competition to find a local alternative to Gar and
imported substance derived from red algae.
At the time it was used in labs as a culture, medium to study bacteria.
How does one? The competition has entry into the contest.
A few lines describing the new substance was accepted as a dissertation thesis.
Moreover, he received further praise and recognition from the party itself while
completing his medical internship.
He was given a leadership position in a bacteriological department,
supervising scientific teams producing the new culture.
Medium in exchange though, have to join the Nazi party as much later declared.
He had run out of reasons.
Well, the first 1939,
the long dark night of Europe began as German troops crossed the border.
And deponents many doctors have been drafted into the armed forces,
but as Hans became Dr. Munch, he was labeled indispensable.
He was not drafted.
And his military authorities asked him to stay in Germany to replace other
physicians who had been sent to the fronts during the early months of world war
two,
Dr. Munch was in a small countryside hospital in Bavaria acting as a replacement
for an absent medical officer while stationed there. He met NS,
married his wife, also a fellow doctor against our wishes in 19, 1941.
Huns volunteered to join the armed forces as motivation and patriotism,
as well as feelings of guilt. He,
a young man had a comfortable position in the countryside hospital while older
doctors were dying on the front line. Hums were still indispensable though.
And his application was rejected.
He then tried to seek help from his sister secretary at the office of the
general staff.
She arranged a series of meetings with various offices and ministry officials,
but with literal results,
Dr. Munch remains stuck in Bavaria until one day in new neck.
He ran into an old school friends.
Dr. Strasburg Strasburg had told Hans that he was doing well. This,
he had secured a non-specified job with the government when Mudge told him about
his difficulty in joining the military,
the old friend advised that he volunteered for the orphan SS rather than,
than regular army Strausberg was an SS officer himself and was actually part of
the staff of Reinhardt Heidrick.
The SNS second in command munch was delighted about the encounter that the
Waffen SS, the fighting units of the organization,
joining them would mean helping fellow troops at the fronts. In other words,
he could fulfill his duty as a patriotic German at that time,
he did not suspect.
So at least he claimed he did not suspect the orphan SS could be also
involved in the administration of the concentration camps.
Moreover munch had little knowledge of the camps or again, so he claimed,
he admitted that he knew about Dachau and other camps in Northern Germany,
but he was allegedly unaware of the extent of the atrocities being perpetrated
when his application was accepted.
And Mudge was told that he would initially be posted near Krakow in Poland after
completing his SS officer training in June of 1943, the Nazis kept that promise,
Dr. Hans munch was posted to the hygiene Institute of the Waffen SS.
And RiceCo now crack out.
This institutes performs all hygienic and bacteriological laboratory work for
the local access of air marks and police units.
It's lab analyzed samples of blood and other fluids do detect cases of typhus,
malaria, and syphilis.
It also managed growth cultures for a variety of bacteria in order to develop
antibiotic treatments and vaccines because of his experience with bacterial
cultures. This was a logical assignment for Dr. Munch.
He later realized that the hygiene Institute was assigned regular shipments of
beef to be used in the bacterial cultures. The meat, however,
was often seized by assets officers for culinary purposes.
The lab technicians sent to make do with other materials do replace the
confiscated beef.
Typically it was human flesh coming from the corpses of prisoners resistance
fighters, dissidents, homosexuals, religious minorities,
Roma Cindy Jews. In other words,
undesirables whose dead bodies could be provided in industrial quantities by a
structure located some four kilometers from Bryce,
go in a place called Oswiecim. And this is better known by its German name.
I was going to borrow a tree.
It was one of many satellite facilities of the larger outfits back in our
complex, which was dedicated to medical, chemical, and pharmacological work.
The hygiene Institute's main task was to control outbreaks of infectious
diseases at the campus is to trial new medicines.
Other facilities and medical teams were purposefully dedicated to dangerous
unethical experimentation on human subjects.
The most infamous cases of the angel of death, Dr. Joseph Mengele,
whose biography we've already covered on this channel,
Mengele was particularly notorious for his trials on identical twins.
The so-called perfect specimens.
One could serve as a control subject while the other Intuit the experiments.
It was the environment that welcomed Dr. Mudge decent man,
with this interest in Nazi ideology and with no ambitions of advancing his own
career at the expense of unwilling test subjects.
Munch later stated that after visiting the main camp for the first time with his
wife, both were shocked.
His wife refused to take lodgings and RiceCo and returned to Germany,
could harms have done the same. In a later interview,
he claims that SS officers and soldiers did not have a choice to leave
Auschwitz. Once they had been assigned to it.
This was disputed by the interviewer Dagmar Osterman as an Auschwitz prisoner.
She was forcibly drafted as clerical helper into an administrative office within
the camp that she processed several requests of SS personnel who would rather go
to the front than serve at Auschwitz. So if he had the chance to leave,
why did he stay dark diminish claims that after his initial months of the
Institute,
coworkers and prisoners themselves asked him not to leave as he was needed that.
So why did they need him? Because very early on,
Dr. Munch behaved like one of the only real human beings on the German side of
the camp, like a real doctor,
more loyal to the Hippocratic oath than to the third Reich.
The hygienic institutes was staffed by some hundred prisoners,
mostly Jewish and Polish. With previous experience in medicine and lab research,
they worked at rice goat,
essentially a skilled slave labor and under munches direct supervision.
As they joined the Institute,
these workers would be marched in and mistreated by SS guards.
Munch was the only one who took time to meet each one in person shaking their
hands and welcoming them to the Institute.
The simple act of civility put him under the spotlight of his superiors.
Someone nudged me that my behavior was unacceptable. One prisoner,
Dr. Lewis miracles also worked with them daily and described ministers friendly.
He showed personal interest in people never humiliated anyone.
He seemed oddly out of place. Now, just before we continue with today's video,
I do want to take a moment to thank who's made it possible.
And that's curiosity,
stream curiosity stream is a subscription streaming service that offers
thousands of documentaries and non-fiction titles from some of the world's best
filmmakers, including exclusive originals. Now, if you're enjoying this one,
then why not try out curiosity stream for free and check out their docu-series
called apocalypse world war two.
If you want to get a bigger picture on what's going on in today's video,
that's a great documentary to check out.
Curiosity stream is available on pretty much every platform you can imagine.
Roku, Android. X-Box one smart TVs. iOS. That list really does go on. Look,
if you've got a screen it was made in the last 10 years,
you're probably going to be able to watch curiosity stream on it.
It's also available worldwide.
No geo restrictions get unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month.
And for you guys, the first 30 days completely free.
If you sign up at curiosity,
stream.com forward slash biographics and use the promo code biographics during
the signup process,
that's a great way to support the show and let's get back to it.
[Inaudible].
Looking off to the staff at Roscoe was one of the reasons for munch to stay.
The other was related to the infamous block. 10.
This was a ward where the chief medical officer at Auschwitz,
Dr. Edward worths studied new diagnostic methods for cervical
cancer, useful research,
but carried out on subjects without their informed consent.
Since April the first 1943,
Lockton was also the theater of sterilization experiments here,
Dr. Carla clawback sought a method for sterilizing unsuspecting women.
He devised a technique of injecting a caustic substance into a patient's uterus
over the course of what she thought was an ordinary gynecological examination.
A camp survivor. Describe these experiments.
A wide substance was then injected into my uterus.
The syringe was about 30 centimeters,
long such injections were done to me three times with breaks of three or four
months after each injection, I had a terrible burning sensation in my abdomen,
Dr. Claire Berg was assisted by an us Sylvia effort,
Jewish prisoner from Slovakia,
Dr. Moon shoot worked occasionally unblocked and described her as being about 20
years old, tall, and very beautiful. More importantly,
she was Claire Berg's right-hand and demanded, absolute respect as she selected,
which women would sent to the gas chambers, uh,
back and out when Doug was moved to another post,
some 25 young women were still in block 10.
The function was now to provide saliva samples to the hygiene Institute in rice
go.
But eventually when she superiors Austin determinates the collection of saliva,
as innocuous as it sounded,
the cessation of saliva samples was a death sentence for those women.
Now that they weren't nice involved in experiments any longer,
they were going to be gassed.
Dr. Munch could not accept that during a sleepless night, he devised a plan.
He concocted a new experiments requiring these women as participants,
a clinical trial,
to assess the efficacy of a new vaccine against granuloma and infection of the
gums.
The project was approved and he was able to save the young women with blocker
10. He owns them.
You must tell everyone that these experiments are very painful and disagreeable
so that the headquarters people do not get wind of anything.
This was one of many instances in which Dr. Munch designs, new homeless trials,
or extended pre-existing experiments to ensure test subjects were not marched to
the infamous showers of the camp.
He found ways to help prisoners more directly as well and official court
document later stated he was helpful in the frame of his possibilities and even
risking his own safety. For example, Dr. Munch helps women,
prisoners meets their husbands in secrets. He succeeded in exempting.
These two inmates from the punishment battalion,
and he ensured the transfer away from Bryce,
go of an SS guard against whom the prisoners had complained prisoner and
colleague, Dr. Morales became very ill with appendicitis in the summer of 1944.
Munch visited him frequently.
UNC was convalescing ensuring that McCall's had a full recovery after five
weeks, Dr. Miracles returned to the Institute,
but it was very weak due to a lack of food. On his first day back,
munch approached him and with great secrecy pulled something out of his pocket.
It was an item you had smuggled to help make ELLs with his recovery.
A nice sausage munch ordered McCall's to eat and have some rest intervening.
When an SS gone grumbled that the prisoner was not on duty later that summer in
1944, Dr. Munch was required to expand his normal duties.
Auschwitz had just received a great influx of Jewish prisoners from Hungary.
It was then that all medical personnel on the site were drafted to take part in
the infamous selection process. Colloquially known as ramp duty.
This is when doctors examined prisoners as they stepped off transport trains and
decided who would work,
who would be used in experiments and who would be sent directly to the gas
chambers, the chief medical officer at Auschwitz,
Edward Wirth insisted that all doctors participated in ramp duty,
but Dr. Munch would not participate in this arbitrary selection,
thinly disguised power trip,
presiding over the life and death of thousands of innocent men,
women and children. Dr. Werth may have had authority over doctors at Auschwitz,
but munch formally reported to Paul.
Reichel the head of all hygienic institutes headquartered in Berlin. Munch,
contacted him and told him I cannot do it. I will not do it.
Regardless of the consequences.
His boss understood after pulling some strings with the camp commander,
he had much exempted from the selection process. More importantly,
there were no direct consequences. Proving again,
that inside of Auschwitz and SS officer was the only person who has ever treated
with any shred of respect or humanity.
In January.
We have 1945 SSL authorities began the evacuation of Auschwitz as the red army
pressed closer from the East,
all the Jewish prisoners working at RiceCo received the news that they would be
transferred to an unknown destination.
The lab workers were reluctant suspecting that they were going to be sent on a
death March headed by Dr. Miracles. They decided to talk to munch.
He shared their concerns and even suggested helping them in a daring escape
attempts.
He would procure SS uniforms and walks them through the Gates of Auschwitz to
freedom. Eventually they agreed. It was safer to join the transport column,
then escaped toward the Swiss Alps.
Dr. [inaudible] survived the late stages of the war and wrote about his last
goodbye with Dr. Munch to prove as Goodwill.
He gave us a revolver in his ammunition in case we have to shoot all why out is
your cans with each of us and wish to Saudi freedom?
That was the last I saw of him. Document was also evacuated.
They spent two months in Dachau and then returned home to Bavaria,
but he wasn't able to hide the fact that he had been a doctor at Auschwitz hums
was eventually arrested by the allied occupation authorities and interned in an
American pow camp. From that he was transferred to Krakow in 1946.
He was to sit on the bench of the accused at the first Auschwitz trial from
November the 24th to December the 22nd,
1947 42 former staff from the concentration camp were put on trial.
23 of the defendants were sentenced to death.
21 of them were hanged on January the 28th,
1948 to have their sentences commuted to life.
Imprisonment 18 defendants were found guilty and sentenced to various terms in
prison. Only one out of all of them was acquitted and released Dr.
Hans munch, the righteous doctor, the good man of Auschwitz during the trial.
The main judge against him was that he had injected prisoners with malaria
infected blood.
It was alleged that he had caused dramatic fever by injecting an unknown agent
into his human Guinea pigs.
But many former prisoners came out in support of munch,
Dr. Louis miracles and other surviving Jews sent their testimonies to Monk's
former boss, Paul Reichel the crack,
our court acknowledged how munch had refused to carry out the selection process.
And how are we going to help prisoners with bogus experiments?
It emerged that he had never inoculated malaria and that his injections were
intended to treat rheumatism rather than cause it on the 22nd of December,
the court acquitted him with the following motivation,
not only because he did not commit any crime of harm against the camp prisoners,
but because he had a benevolent attitude toward them and helps them.
He did this independently from the nationality,
race and religious origin and political conviction of the person.
After the trial.
Munch,
Roseanne into Germany and began working as a practicing doctor in rails Hopton
Bavaria for many years,
neither munch nor his spoke to their children about his experience at Auschwitz.
All they knew was that he had been on trial,
but that he had been acquitted it's on Doug, latest out.
I think my father was somewhat paralyzed.
He could not talk very much to his children about what he saw and felt in the
decades. After the end of the war,
Dr. Munch became a sought after witness and expert.
His opinion was consulted by prosecutors, journalists,
and survivors to shed light on the atrocities perpetrated at Auschwitz.
For example, in 1955,
Dr. [inaudible] the torture of block 10 returns to West Germany,
right after the war,
he had been arrested by the Soviets and kept in captivity for a decade upon his
return.
He made several public statements about the medical importance of his work at
Auschwitz survivors of blockchain and their families immediately petitioned for
Colberg to be tried in June of 1946, Dr.
Munch was then approached by prosecutors and he volunteered his testimony,
providing valuable details about the activities of Colberg and his right-hand
woman nurseries to RAF. Some years later,
moonshot was summons to the second dash Fitz trial. This time as a key witness,
the second trial was held in Frankfurt from December the 10th,
1963 to August the 10th, 1965,
22 former SS officers and guards were indicted for their complicity in war
crimes. Thanks to much testimony.
18 were found guilty and sentenced to various terms of imprisonment.
During the early 1980s,
Dr. Mudge participated into documentary films produced for German TV,
the director of one of them,
Bernard Frankfurter later arranged for the doctor to meet with a camp survivor
Dagmar, Osterman,
whom we already quoted Dagmar interviewed hands lengths in April of 1988.
The transcripts was later published in the book,
titled the meeting and Auschwitz survivor confronts and SS physician.
The interview sheds light on how and why munch eventually joined the Nazi party
and the SS.
It also reveals many details on how exactly it helps prisoners at the camp.
However, the editors of the book, Frankfurter and Susan Cerney expense,
also a camp survivor offer a different interpretation.
They posit that munch knew very well.
What was going on at Auschwitz long before working there and that he stated his
post in rice gal out of opportunism and chrism mitigated by sporadic
acts of kindness. In August of 1993,
[inaudible] was interviewed by another Auschwitz survivor, either Moses core,
either into twin sister, Miriam had arrived at the camp in the spring of 1944,
age 10, their parents,
and two older sisters almost immediately selected to die in the gas chambers.
The twins were chosen by Dr. Mengele to be among his test subjects.
When the Soviets liberated Auschwitz on January the 27th, 1945,
only 200 out of three thousands of Mandela's twins that survived
Eva and Miriam are among the lucky few. When Marianne died,
Eva opens in her memory, the candles museum and Terre Haute,
Indiana candles stands for children of Auschwitz, Nazi death,
lab experiments survivors, while organizing a conference on Nazi medicine,
Eva decided to contact Dr. Munch. She wanted to know more about Dr. Mengele,
but Huns couldn't give her much insight. He knew him,
but he had not worked alongside him either at questioned him about the operation
of the gas chambers. And he replied, this is the nightmare I live with.
I had to watch the operation of the gas chambers,
and then when the bodies were dead, I had to sign the death certificates.
Wounds provide a detailed descriptions on how the pallets of colorless odorless
cycle on B gas were dropped through the advent, since the mock showers,
this was a precious testimony.
One that would finally shut the tramp of those few remaining morons who denied
the existence of the gas chambers or even worse deny that the Shoah and the
extermination of other undesirables ever took place. Two years later,
munchkin Eva joined forces again for a special event.
It was the 27th of January, 1995,
the 50th anniversary of the liberation of Auschwitz on Eva's invitation,
Dr. Munez joins the televised commemoration during which Eva read two documents
that they had authored and signed.
The first one was a declaration by Dr. Munch in which he attempted the existence
of the gas chambers. I saw thousands of people, gas tear at Auschwitz, children,
old people, the sick and those unable to work were sent to the gas chambers.
These were innocent human beings, Jews gypsies, homosexuals,
Hitler's political opponents,
anyone who did not fit Hitler's idea of pure Aryan race.
I am signing this paper of my own free will to help documents the cruel
intolerance of my fellow.
SS I a format SS physician witnessed the dropping of Zyklon B into simulated
exhaust vents from outside the gas chambers up to three to five minutes.
Death could be certified. This is the nightmare I continue to live with.
50 years later, Eva's document was equally powerful in her declaration.
She had decided to forgive the torture iron's execution as an Auschwitz,
even Dr. Mengele, I even most as core in my name,
only give this amnesty because it is time to go on.
It is time to heal our souls. It is time to forgive,
but never forget.
Never forget.
That was the main message carried by Hans Eva and others who had designed it to
document the darkness of the concentration camps.
Individual memories are the greatest weapon against the return of such darkness,
but the memory of an individual can be fickle and unreliable,
especially in old age when the ravages of dementia and Alzheimer's disease can
wipe clean the slate of one's memory or distorted changing the perception of
the presence and its interpretation of the past. Sadly,
that is what happens during the final act of Dr. Hahn's munches life.
In November of 1998, he was interviewed by a German magazine dish Spiegel,
often a viewing of Steven Spielberg's Schindler's list.
Dr. Munch was a household name and widely known as the good man from Auschwitz.
And yes, during the interview, he made several shocking disparaging,
hateful comments about the Jewish people and even praised Dr. Mengele,
his work Mengele, and the others sent us their material heads, livers,
spinal fluid, whatever came up, munch claims. It was thanks.
This provision of organic material that he could perform experiments in ideal
conditions. He even mentioned intentionally infecting prisoners with malaria.
The interview was followed by another media appearance in a French radio station
during the broadcast,
which stated there's Romer and Cindy prisoners at Auschwitz were pathetic.
And that the gas chambers with the right solution to get rid of them,
both his son and daughter were aghast at these comments.
They revealed to the media that their father had been suffering from Alzheimer's
disease for a while. Now, it almost completely lost his short-term memory.
And he lived in a state of mental confusion.
This is the explanation on which most media outlets agreed upon.
After all his conduct at Auschwitz had been clearly documented at the first
trial shortly after the war.
Many witness accounts from prisoners had exonerated him from atrocities,
especially infecting prisoners with deadly diseases, munches declarations,
nonetheless sparked two court proceedings in France and Germany on counts of
instigating racial hatred and supporting Nazi ideology.
In the case of the French trial in 2001, harms munch was convicted in absentia.
Although a medical commission recognized him as being severely,
psychologically disturbed. The verdict never reached him. Dr. Hans munch,
then 90 years old had passed away and his family home in our Gallop of area.
Now I'm not going to ask you if you enjoyed today's video,
but I do hope that the story of hunting says inspired you to study and keep
alive the memory of what happens in the camps and other Auschwitz,
survivor Primo levy warned us that it happens. Therefore it can happen again.
This is the core of what we have to say is can happen and it can happen
everywhere.